[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue vous favorable à
l'expérience de zone sans contrôle
d'identité vous savez c'est l'expérience
que propose la défenseure des droits à
claire et dont c'est la question qu'on
vous pose également sur twitter et on
l'a posera ce soit à philippe meyer
bonsoir philippe bond sera animateur
faut-il le rappeler du nouvel esprit
public à retrouver sur le web le nouvel
esprit public le nouvel esprit public
sans séparation point fr est avec nous
avec vous également ce soir comme chaque
mardi alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro bonsoir il au
figaro sans séparation point fr et
effectivement figaro la vie sans
séparation également l'édito d'alexis
est encore en ligne recombiner disait-il
eh bien on en reparle ce soir avec un
débat cette fois ci autour des
spectacles des buses et des cinémas des
concerts en un mot faut-il libéré sans
attendre la culture c'est donc l'autre
débat mais d'abord on revient sur la
polémique soulevée par la proposition la
défenseure des droits en fin de semaine
dernière clair et donc proposé de tester
des zones sans contrôle d'identité
colère des syndicats de police en
particulier le syndicat des commissaires
de police scpn qui a diffusé sur son
compte twitter des images que l'on a
vues et que vous avez pu voir sur le
site du figaro d'agression et de
guet-apens samedi à poissy dans les
yvelines et en commentaire de ces images
on pouvait lire sur le sur le compte
twitter
la défenseure des droits promeut la
création de zones sans contrôle
d'identité c'est à dire de non-droit et
bien là défenseur des droits a répondu
ce matin au micro de sonia mabrouk
on écoute je n'ai jamais souhaité mettre
fin au contrôle d'identité
j'ai simplement dit que l'absence dans
certaines zones de contrôles d'identité
sans traçabilité
bien sûr il ya des moments où il faut
ces contrôles je m'inquiète de l'utilité
à certains moments de ces contrôles
d'identité et c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut les quantifier qu'il faut
mener des expérimentations jeu
redit que j'ai bien parlé
d'expérimentation et quand on
expérimente plusieurs méthodes
on ne sait pas avant quelle sera la
meilleure est alors sans attendre
l'expérience proposée par est clair et
dont voici la réponse ce matin de du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
j'allais c'est bien mal connaître le
travail de la police que délecter de ces
débats je pense pas qu'il doit y avoir
en france évidemment des endroits où la
police n'a pas le droit d'aller vous
n'avez loi de contrôle et bien sûr qu'il
ya sans doute des manquements à la
déontologie
mais la quasi intégralité des contrôles
de police se passe sans problème et à 5
million de contrôles de police et de
gendarmes d'opérations de police et
comme chaque année 99 12 7% de ses
contrôles ne donne lieu à aucun
signalement les policiers les gendarmes
de france ils font leur travail
la quasi-intégralité d'entre eux alors
philippe vous fier aux chiffres de
gérald darmanin ou bien à ceux de claire
hédon qui dit que dans 95 % des cas les
contrôles d'identité ne servent à rien
je ne me fais en rien aux chiffres de
monsieur darmanin qui sont en plus
absurde 99,7 % de contrôle qui se passe
sans problème
il tient et tire sa douche c'est à peu
près comme si on nous avait expliqué il
ya deux mois qui avait pas d'inceste en
france ou qui en avait que 1 sur 1
million de d'habitants il n'y a pas de
statistiques parce qu'il n'ya pas de
plainte
et d'ailleurs quand il ya des plaintes
c'est arrivé jusqu'à la cour de
cassation qu'elle juge et je me souviens
plus très bien si un ou deux ils savent
que en 2016 non 2006 et la cour d'appel
froid et ensuite la cour de cassation se
prononce en tout cas c'est assez récent
vont au pape que y avait en effet un
certain nombre de problèmes
c'est arrivé quand le prédécesseur de
madame et dont jacques toubon le
gauchiste bien connu vous savez celui
qui a des dreadlocks et puis qu'est un
couteau en travers de la bouche avait
fait remarquer qu' il y avait vingt fois
plus de chances d'être contrôlé si on
n'était pas de peau blanche que sur
l'été de peau blanche
donc il ya un problème est-ce que la
solution madame et dont est la bonne
je ne sais pas j'allais dire l'hédonisme
passera-t-il ou ne passera t'il pas je
n'en sais rien mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que ya à l'intérieur des banlieues
quelque chose qui ressemble fort une
poudrière et que tout ce qu'on peut
faire pour désamorcer cette poudrière
c'est-à-dire pour donner à ceux qui
habitent le sentiment qu'ils diront
l'objet d'une d'une forme de
considération spéciale je pense que ce
serait bien pour une fois j'ai fini pour
varier un vrai désaccord car je me sente
enfin d accord je pense effectivement
que les banlieues sont une vraie
poudrière
et que faire donner si peu que ce soit
l'impression aux habitants des banlieues
qu'on les abandonne serait une
catastrophe c'est précisément ce que
propose cette madame claire hédon
défenseur des droits nommé par emmanuel
macron c'est de créer des zones de
non-droit elle devient défenseurs du non
droit
dire qu'en banlieue les policiers
n'auraient plus le droit de contrôler
des identités ça veut dire déjà au cclat
police dans certains quartiers a grand
mal à pénétrer
ça veut dire que ces quartiers entiers
se relèverait davantage qu'ils le sont
aujourd'hui à la loi des bandes des
gangs et des bandes
ça veut dire que les pauvres habitants
de ces quartiers sur les victimes
abandonnées par les habitants des beaux
quartiers
je sais pas où habite madame claire
hédon mais tous ces beaux esprits nous
disent mais laissons les là-bas dans ces
quartiers mais que le trafic de drogue
continue et puis après tout peu importe
pour les pauvres gens qui habitent dans
des immeubles qui sont où on peut même
plus entrer le soir parce qu'il est
tellement il ya de trafic où les
voitures se sont cramés régulièrement ou
où on doit montrer patte blanche avant
d'entrer dans son quartier parce qu'il
ya des guetteurs à l'entrée du quartier
ont dit toi tu rentres tu rentres et on
regarde dans ton sac c'est un truc
invraisemblable donc cette claire hédon
et c'est absolument délirant d'oser dire
ça délirant de mépris social d'oser
prétendre que dans certains quartiers ne
faut pas faire de contrôle alors qu'on
aurait le droit de les faire dans le 16e
arrondissement
oulaï a aucun problème non je pense que
nous aurions tort de nous focaliser sur
madame aidons à ces jeux les biens non
mais j'ai dit à l'instant que je n'étais
pas du tout convaincu que ce qu'elle
propose est la bonne solution par contre
je suis convaincu qu'il ya un problème
avec les contrôles d'identité au faciès
et que ce qui serait positif aussi bien
vis-à-vis de respect de la loi que
vis-à-vis du respect des personnes qui
n'ont pas enfreint ces de revenir à une
doctrine est une application des
contrôles d'identité qui soit conforme
au code pénal c'est à dire au fait que
soit il y avait je reprends ya flagrant
délit soit ya risque à l'ordre public
soit ya réquisitions du procureur de la
république
dans ces conditions là tous les exemples
mon cher lexique vous avez pris ne sont
en aucun cas susceptibles d'être à
l'abri de l'action de la police mais ce
qui me paraît nécessaire et d'ailleurs
je vois bien peut-être que emmanuel
macron s'en mord un peu les doigts ce
matin mais enfin cet après midi mais je
veux bien que son côté en même temps
c'est à dire d'un côté d'armani ya
jamais de problème dans cette relation
et de l'autre côté madame et donc qui
dit ce qu'elle vient de dire c'est dieu
en même temps qui me semble un peu fait
faire le grand écart à ce point là au
risque de se claquer les muscles quand
même mais je pense encore une fois que
la question des contrôles d'identité du
contrôle d'autant plus que d'ailleurs
dans les études qui avait été fait pour
le défenseur des droits qui précède est
clair et dont un certain nombre de
policiers s'est exprimé pour dire que
c'était des contrôles d'identité
absolument inutiles qui était fait pour
faire du chiffre mais non je ne crois
pas que les cantons devraient soit fait
par faire du chiffre
les contrôles d'identité sont faits pour
pourquoi on demande pas des gens n'ont
pas très bien savoir s'ils ont des
papiers c'est généralement dans le cadre
d'opérations notamment contre les
stupéfiants ou contre agitation sur les
étranges à discuter bon ben donc ces
contrôles dogues sont à 10 de ces
contrôles la part dont on les fait dans
les quartiers on soupçonne qu'ils aient
dû les trafics de stupéfiants
c'est partir on les connaît les
habitants de ces quartiers on n'y peut
rien si ce sont les habitants de ces
quartiers
premièrement les infractions à la loi
sur les sur le séjour
là encore quand on est chargé de faire
du contrôle orienté c'est pas pour ça
est-ce que vous avez envoyé c est ce que
vous êtes en infraction rapport loi sur
le séjour c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
aller vers les gens dont on soupçonne
qu'il faut qu'ils sont en infraction
vers la loi sur le séjour et là encore
sinon faut pas faire de contrôle du tout
mais je vais pas demander aux policiers
de faire des contrôles sur les
infractions au séjour et de leur dire
allez dans le 16e arrondissement vous
contrôlez vous contribuez disent non et
je sais qu'il est pas en infractions sur
le séjour
donc c'est pas la peine donc au monde il
n'y a pas de contrôle ou si on essaie de
faire des contrôles en effet ce tour
pour endiguer ce nombre de problèmes
l'immigration clandestine le trafic de
stupéfiants le vol de véhicules et donc
quand on arrête un jeune à scooter ont
regardé souvent on lui demande ses
papiers d'identité ont dit ce scooter il
est à toi mais que si on sait pas qui
on peut pas savoir si le scooter est à
lui donc ça fait quand même partie de
ces choses et puis c'est aussi un moyen
est là c'est le moyen de faire qui peut
être contestable
mic en même temps je crois dans une
logique de contrôle du territoire se
comprend c'est aussi un moyen d'affirmer
une présence parce que la réalité c'est
un centre de quartier les caïds sont les
patrons et de temps en temps pour dire
vous n'êtes pas les patrons on en voit
deux malheureux policier mais
franchement ils sont pas demandeurs ont
laurent les affaires des contrôles pour
pour dire la république peut être encore
la ddt alors on peut dire c'est
malheureux d'en être arrivé là
mais ce qui est malheureux c'est pas les
contrôles que font les policiers ce qui
est malheureux c'est la situation dans
ces quartiers contre laquelle on ne fait
rien et ça dépend renonce à envoyer la
police dans ces quartiers qu'on
arrangera les choses on mettra la
poussière sur le tapis ce qui me frappe
moi c'est que c'est toutes ces dérives
le trafic de stupéfiants et toutes ces
choses là toutes ces violences
deviennent graves dès lors qu'elles sont
dans paris d'excellents bon on s'en
fiche on considère que c'est des autres
de nombreux ben non on peut pas je
philippe quand on regarde pardon je le
sais image là peut-être les revoir donc
de ce qui s'est passé à poissy et
surtout de ce qu'on entendait c'est à
dire que les assaillants que l'on voit
ici disent oh peu à propos des policiers
tués les tuer les cds images qui sont
passés à poissy c'est des images on a
des scènes qui sont comparables qui sont
passés à roubaix des scènes qui sont
passés des scènes comparables également
à villiers-le-bel je voulais me trois
exemples il y en a sans doute d'autres
ce week end
est ce que la question de savoir si les
contrôles d'identité pas de contrôle 81
l'identité c'est même plus le problème
en ce 10 mai pour le presser le savoir
via leur lit c'est pas le problème comme
c'est pas le problème dans les exemples
que vous avez cités dans d'autres
exemples antérieures où il ya eu contre
la police des violences sans compter
ceux qui se sont fait tuer ce couple qui
s'est effectuée sans compter en cas ils
seraient 200 policiers l'allégeance et
non 20 policiers toujours qu'ils sont
victimes de
les séparent violence tout ça est
absolument indiscutable ne peut pas être
minimisée ne peut pas non plus être
maximisée je veux dire faut pas non plus
où il essayait de faire croire comme le
syndicat policier qui diffuse cette
vidéo essaye de le faire entre
parenthèses je pense que les syndicats
de policiers n'ont pas plus vocation à
faire la politique de sécurité que les
organisations de médecins à faire la
politique sanitaire
mais revenons à ça il faut pas essayer
de nous faire croire que l'espèce de
pauvre type qui crie tuer les tuer les
allées vraiment tuer quelqu'un c'est à
dire c'est youtube quelqu'un avec qui on
voit bien qu'il ya un milliard mené bon
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui est neuf dans
un état de d'excitation dont on se
demande s'ils ne relèvent pas d'un
double d'une part de la police pour le
calmer et d'autre part d'un psychiatre
pour essayer de le nettoyer l'intérieur
de la tête mais je pense que dans les
exemples que alexis après tout à l'heure
le lac presque tous les exemples
l'action de la police avec contrôle
d'identité elle va de soi quand tu y as
c'est d'ailleurs les trois cas qui sont
prévues par le code pénal le procureur
de la république le flagrant délit et le
et de troubles à l'ordre public dont
voilà mais c'est moins c'est moins
évident pour ce qui est des titres de
séjour moins évident pour ce qui est des
titres de séjour c'est plus compliqué là
dessus on aimerait bien savoir un peu
quelle est la doctrine parce que
j'aimerais qu'un bon vaut de la sécurité
je sais pas il en est pas encore sorti
grand chose pour le moment mais je pense
que le comment dire le poids que pèse à
l'intérieur de la police des syndicats
auxquels le ministre ne résiste pas plus
que son prédécesseur
on va être un vrai problème sur le bord
de la sécurité je crois qu'on fait un
point justement dans le figaro dans les
prochaines heures oui me reposer une
question puisqu'on parle des cd4 police
et fils ne disons pas absolument
vocation intervenir dans le débat plus
nous on intervient dans le débat mais
pas faire la politique bien entendre le
pose la question c'est est-ce que
l'ancienne présidente d'akd et d'écarts
monde ancien journaliste à radio france
à vocation d expliquer comment des
employés les forces de l'ordre moi je
m'interroge sur ne sera dire que cette
dévoiement de l'institution du défenseur
des droits
le défenseur des droits avait écrit faut
rappeler par sarkozy c'était la
commission balladur
c'était de la succession de fusion qui
succède au médiateur en gros c'était
pour que les citoyens résistants
l'emploi l'empiètement d'administration
tatillonne bureaucratique les impôts
leaf à tous et toutes formalités et
c'est devenu une sorte de conseil
national des droits de l'homme auprès
duquel la cour européenne est dangereuse
instance répressive avec une espèce de
surenchère dans le désarmement policiers
légèrement sucré cutter lequel tout bon
absolument participer qu'à vous faisait
une caricature de double en dreadlocks
c'est du tout bon vient certes de la
droite mais ça fait bien bien bien bien
bien longtemps qu'il s'est donné
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
mal pour faire oublier qu'il avait été
un peu un peu de droite et est il lui
même si lens est une dérive alors
maintenant le sa successeure qui étaient
nommés par macro est une militante
humanitaire c'est très honorable son
métier atd quart monde s'était approprié
de protéger notamment les immigrants et
l'immigration clandestine
bon évidemment il n'est pas pour les
contrôles d'identité je veux pas lui
reprocher moralement mais après il faut
pas est ce que c'est ça les droits est
ce que les droits c'est toujours les
droits des gens contre les droits de la
république et contre les droits de la
collectivité
c'est un concept qui mérite d'être
interrogé comment alors c'est comme vous
l'avez compris j'ai davantage de
sympathie pour ce café jacques toubon
je ne pense pas que ce soit simplement
pour tomber à gauche comme on disait
autrefois
mais je sais par ailleurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler un peu parce
que je faisais pour le nouvel esprit
public une émission thématique sur le
défenseur des droits et j'ai vu à quel
point le défenseur des droits joue un
rôle important dans la vie quotidienne
des français face à leur administration
et dans l'administration face aux
français car souvent les deux sont aussi
désormais les uns que les autres mais
peu importe il a en effet émana m en
entendant claire hédon ce matin on
apprenait qu'un outil un fort lobbying
d'un certain nombre d'associations
auprès de cet institut et y compris les
droits de l'homme qui défilait que
j'essayais non je tiens à répéter tout à
fait dans le que j'ai dit je ne suis pas
l'avocat de madame et dont je ne connais
pas madame est donc auquel était radio
france je crois à peu près nous y avons
été ensemble à l'intérieur à l'occasion
de la rencontre et de radio france avait
renoncé après quelles sont les missions
de santé a priori récente 1 je ne suis
pas du tout encore une fois et de la
seule chose que je garde de ce qu'elle a
dit c'est qu'il y a un problème avec les
gardes à vue et que sur ce plan là
j'aimerais bien avoir une explication
qui ne soit pas recouverte par cette
espèce de dramatisation flamboyante à
coups de vidéos pour les uns et il
contrôle d'identité par dont elle
parlait des contrôles d'identité oui on
regarde et vous voyez à partir duquel on
devrait plus être oui mais alors espérer
ça reprenait l'argument darmanin en dix
ans la même chose
95% des contrôles d'identité ne donne
rien do ça prouve leur inutilité
mais comment on fait pour faire 100 % de
tout contrôle d'identité qui donnerait
quelque chose qui permettrait des greens
d'infraction c'est vrai que doha qu'il
faudrait cibler ciblées sur cibler les
contrôles d'identité
donc les bons elle donne grosso modo aux
mêmes chiffres que darmanin puisque à
10,95 midi 97
mais lui dit c'est la preuve que ça se
passe bien elle dit ça prouve que ça
sert à rien il ya bien un truc qui va
pas non mais je veux c'est de faire de
voir le grand frère va donner de noms
nice tu rêverais en tout cas mais je
continue à penser que d'ailleurs à
propos de ce pauvre il faudra bien aussi
en parler je continue à penser qu'en
matière de doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre et de pratiques de maintien de
l'ordre
on est dans une situation épouvantable
et on l'est par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres pays d'europe dans une
situation affreusement agressif et ça
n'est pas ni les palinodies de d1 mis la
manière dont monsieur darmana se
frappent sur la poitrine ni les
provocations si c'est ça qu'elle a voulu
faire de mal à mes dons qui vont faire
avancer le schmilblick mais on ne peut
pas ne pas nier un oeil à l'ordre public
dans le cadre des manifestations il ya
une vraie remise à jour de nos doctrine
d'intervention qui ne sont plus adaptées
aujourd'hui aussi de la présence de la
police de la présence de la police dans
la société dit qu'ont pris de la
gendarmerie d'ailleurs les réformes
successives de la gendarmerie ont fini
par poser des problèmes à une arme qui
étaient traditionnellement absolument en
symbiose alan immersion il faut voir
vous avez su sans doute raison de ce
point de vue mais dont il voir aussi qui
se joue aujourd'hui confrontés y compris
à la campagne à une violence mais
absolument inédite et est en fait
souvent l'ordre ça repose sur une
convention c'est pas la menace ni l'
usage de la force qui fait respecter
l'ordre c'est que quand on voit un
policier 80 gendarmes ont obéi et ils
sont face maintenant en banlieue mais
pas qu'eux y compris dans les campagnes
face à des populations qui disent banon
et là on fait quoi
face à des gens qui disent non alors
c'est ce que ressentent en tous les cas
les internautes dans l'est
dans l'est dans les commentaires un
internaute au pseudonyme évocateur
philippe à des ce qu'ils nous disent et
faire la part belle à la délinquance
il existe déjà des zones de non-droit
leur offrir des zones sans contrôle
c'est leur faire un cadeau
moi je ne commente pas ce que dit cet
internaute mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ya en tous les cas beaucoup de
ceux ressentis par rapport à ce genre de
proposition alors que les raids ont bien
jacques toubon et qui est dire mais
encore une fois est-ce que le on en est
au contrôle d'identité mais le problème
c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'il ya la
république brûle et qu' on en est encore
à discuter de savoir s'il faut voir les
cartes d'identité de telle ou telle oui
je pense que ce qu avait mis en évidence
le rappeur de tout bon c'était que si la
république brûle s'il ya ces
comportements par alexis qui font que le
respecte humain le fait qu'à des choses
qu'on ne fait pas ce autres deviennent
plus rares ou plus fragiles c'est en
partie parce que il y a à l'égard de
certaines populations des comportements
qui au bout d'un moment les leur font
perdre confiance dans d'envolées france
donc si je devais je travaille là je
parle pas des dealers ni de ce qui ce
faisant je suis entier je suis votre
raisonnement si je l'explicité un peu
c'est qu'on a trop fliquée une partie de
la population issue de l'immigration qui
est qui provoque et ça provoque ces
situations là c'est s'attirer les
passages je dirais qu'on a trop fliquée
ce dont il y avait pas grand chose à
craindre et pas assez flics et ceux qui
sont les délinquants les grands caïds de
la drogue etc etc
je pense plutôt ça et je pense que c'est
plutôt ce que on apprend mais je veux
pas non plus me faire passer pour le
spécialiste que je ne suis pas mais
comme nous tous ces questions là m'ont
beaucoup intéressé puis j'ai commencé ma
vie professionnelle comme éducateur dans
un club de lutte contre la délinquance
juvénile donc j'ai pas complètement
perdu le contact j'ai écrit un livre sur
la gendarmerie après avoir passé le
deux ans entre deux gendarmes si j'ose
dire et à travers la france bref je suis
pas complètement désintéressé de ces
questions là et je pense que oui le
problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas et on
ne sait pas comment faire aujourd'hui
pas plus aujourd'hui qu'hier à moins que
ça sorte du beauvau on va attendre mais
qu'on ne sait pas comment s'en prendre
aux délinquants
ce qu'ils font vraiment le pourrissement
des banlieues et que évidemment c'est
plus facile de se mettre à la sortie du
métro à saint denis et de choper tout ce
qu'ils ont qui en sortent et qui en
général ont dû faire d'une couleur de
peau qui et je dirai la couleur locale
de saint denis
un dernier mot peut-être aller sinon
qu'on passe au deuxième s'est passé au
deuxième rangée voilà alors voilà je
donne la mort la haye la parle pas trop
interne au talent de ceux de ce kit est
sûre sujet proposition ahurissante
l'état doit être en mesure d'assurer sa
présence et son autorité sur tout le
territoire qu'il administre nous dit
quand tu as tout le monde doit être
contrôlée ou personnes un entre-deux est
injuste estime nathalie
c'est le défenseur des droits qu'il faut
supprimer une telle proposition est
inconcevable dit nicole et babineau nous
dit je rejoins je rejoins philippe meyer
les contrôles d'identité aléatoires sont
inefficaces à 95 % c'est un problème
nathan nous dit il ya toujours une
police dans une zone si ce n'est pas
cette de l'état ce sera celle des caïds
mais il y aura une police
la question quand vous posez sur twitter
si je voudrais dire que c'est un
contrôle d'identité diffic à 7 95% ça
veut dire qu'il est efficace à 5%
c'est déjà beaucoup de ses dires sur
sambre personnes qu'on arrête y en a
cinq qui sont dans l'illégalité
pardon à un contrôle d'identité qui
serait efficace à 100% c'est pas un
contrôle d'identité et une descente de
police dans une prison je pense qu'en
fait alexis des emprunts de suggérer que
il faudrait faire des contrôles
d'identité dans le 16e arrondissement
pour montrer qu'on ne persécute pas ceux
qui sont dans le 93
faut-il expérimenter des zones sans
contrôle d'identité c'était la question
que vous posez sur un twitter et vous
répondez non à 83%
l'autre question qu'on vous pose et il a
aussi vous êtes des experts messieurs en
tous les cas vous avez quelque chose à
dire
c'était il ya un an pile un premier
patient atteint du coït décédées en
france à l'hôpital bichat c'était un peu
plus d'un an puisque c'était le 15
février 2020 un mois plus tard qu'on
filme en général sur tout le territoire
depuis plus de spectacle ont quasiment
plus annulation des concerts des
festivals dans les cinémas les salles
sont fermées depuis l'automne pareil
pour les musées alors à beauvais la mère
caroline cayeux propose d'ouvrir à titre
d'expérience ces musées et ce en
coordination avec l'état et elle nous
raconte la suite au bout de 15 jours
nous pourrons relancer les visiteurs et
voir s'il y a eu à gloucester si
certains sont tombés malades ce qui nous
étonnerait parce qu'il ya eu un certain
nombre d'études qui ont été faites et
une dernièrement par l'institut pasteur
disant qu'il y a peu de contagion dans
les lieux de spectacles et de son côté
roselyne bachelot culture fait aussi une
proposition elle concerne les festivals
et les concerts je suis optimiste pour
les spectacles à 6 pour les spectacles
de vous c'est plus compliqué c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que je mène des
expérimentations et ses expérimentations
sont destinés à vraiment bien tester ce
qui se passe nous avons un nous sommes
en train de monter
on n'en définit les modalités deux
concerts deux expérimentations à
marseille avec 6 est ce que c'est bien
raisonnable parce que la culture on
comprend le la patience parce que c'est
un bien essentiel
bien sûr que c'est un bien essentiel
après on ne peut pas raisonner sur la
culture indépendamment de la situation
sanitaire c'est comme ça le le le fond
du tableau qu'elle était l'armé dit
qu'on est des spécialistes sombre est
grandement exagérées on a pris
l'habitude de parler ces questions là
c'est un peu d'ailleurs vu entre là j'en
suis persuadé les uns bardot grosso modo
qu est ce qu on croit comprendre c'est
que la situation donc ton certains nous
l'ont dit et redit redit
quinze jours que ça va être horrible que
dès que si on confie n'est pas allé très
très mal se passer
la solution pour l'instant alors de
plutôt se tenir
l'épidémie ne progresse pas la même
temps semble-t-il à un tout petit peu
régressé notamment quand on considère
l'entrée dans les urgences que le ce
qu'on appelle le finalement le le virus
de traditionnelle est en train de
régresser fortement et dans toute
l'europe parce que ce qui se passe chez
nous se posent dans toute l'europe
tout ça pour dire qu'on sait pas
exactement à quoi quelle cause sa
réponse enfin c'est l'heure de baisser
dans toute l'europe que le variant la
preuve le variant progresse mais que
pour l'instant je dis bien pour
l'instant
ce variant ne semblent pas entraîner un
surcroît de mal-être de malades tels que
ça compense la baisse du variant
traditionnelles doivent bon donc ça veut
dire que ça va pas si mal
donc si ça va pas si mal il est
peut-être temps me semble-t-il sous
réserve que ça empire on sait jamais
mais c'est peut-être temps de commencer
à se dire pourquoi pas réouvrir
et alors des gens me semble t'il encore
en commençant par les musées s'il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui je crois que
faciles à contrôler puis à des
tourniquets d'entrée
puisqu'on vous peut vraiment gérer le
flux d le flux d'aidé personnes dans le
musicien les musées sage
franchement je ne comprends pas pourquoi
le musée philippe à propos des musées
donc là le tribunal administratif a
suspendu la les arrêtés du maire de
perpignan qui permettait à l'ouverture
de quatre musées de la ville la mairie
de perpignan je ne sais pas si ces
chiffres sont justes mais dit qu'il ya
deux mille personnes qui ont visité les
musées si c'est vrai c'est prouve qu'il
ya quand même une envie si c'est vrai
pourquoi ça serait pas vrai vous avez
l'air de soupçonner le maire de
perpignan de trafic et la vérité pas du
tout faits passés n'ont pas dit qu'ils
devaient écouter si c'est vrai on en
reparlera
manque d'avoir quelques éléments pour
vous assurer que c'est vrai pour le
reste quelques l espèce de quelle espèce
de carrousel on a l'impression qu'on est
dans un tambour de machine à laver tout
le monde a un avis absolument
péremptoire c'est à peu près comme pour
de la santé d'ailleurs ses vues je dit
pas son nom parce que ça sert à rien
mais une actrice assez connus qui
avaient un air épouvantablement la
valeur de dire mais comment tous sont
ces gens incapables s'occupe de la
politique culturelle alors que au
portugal tout est ouvert au portugal
tout est ouvert toutes les salles de
réanimation sont ouverts à tous et parce
que tout a été fermée étant donné la
probable à la progression du virus
g j'ai parlé à des amis britanniques
pardon fait un usage en ingénierie non
pas du tout c'était pas elle je vous
dirai qui sait hors antenne mais je
n'exonère jeudi
il peut engager une série d'aidés selon
ses défenseurs
j'ai parlé à des amis britanniques
samedi qui eux sont prêts à donner la
nationalité britannique à roselyne
bachelot à la ferme mais conteste par la
reine duchesse tout ce que vous voudrez
à la faire venir avec sa politique parce
que eux qui sont dans une troupe de
théâtre qui connu dans le monde qui joue
et qui joue depuis 30 ans ils en sont
revenus à la situation qui était la leur
quand ils ont commencé en pire parce que
quand ils ont commencé il était comme
beaucoup de comédiens et gagner leur
croûte en étant serveurs dans des bars
dans des hôtels sauf que plus de bar il
ya plus d'hôtels dans climat parce
qu'ils voudraient la politique de retour
des vaches l'origine des habiletés il se
fiche de recensement perdu leur est égal
il voudrait absolument ce régime des
intermittents qui est extraordinairement
protecteur et c'est là dessus que je
reçois d'un habit cinéastes et des
romans le commandeur des arts et lettres
une caricature dont il a l'air d'être le
supporters ardant dans laquelle on voit
recommencé après noël
la mère de charles o 9 lors des guerres
de religion catherine de médicis qui est
peinte devant d'espèces de cadavres
plats phares et la légende et roselyne
bachelot venant prendre des nouvelles
des intermittents je dis ah bon alors je
lui réponds je dis mais ferait quand
même les intermittents il me semble
qu'ils ont la chance de toucher quelque
chose oui mais enfin on ne peut pas
s'intéresser qu'à cet aspect là des
choses vont très bien sur quoi j'ai eu
ce matin coup de téléphone de 40 minutes
et qu'un ami qui tient une péniche en
face de l'île saint louis opont mari
s'appelle marcoux net google qui vous au
jazz où il fait beaucoup de jeu qui lui
dit mais merci seigneur on a dix mille
euros par mois pour faire tourner notre
truc et mon collaborateur
il a 80 % de son salaire grâce grâce au
chômage partiel fin à l'activité
partielle et enfin il vous croirez si
vous voulez mais cros bois croix de fer
si je mens je vais en enfer je croise un
ami comédien tout à l'heure rue vivienne
qui je lui dis comment ça va et ils me
regardent furieux il me dit mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce truc enfin qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent pour je dis merci
d'attendre pourquoi mais pour confiner
j'ai commencé pour confirmer oui qu'on
nous confine une bonne fois pour toute
et puis comme ça on sera régresser le
virus et on pourra recommencer
alors voilà un panorama de ce que j'ai
entendu en l'espace de moins de huit
jours alors filière outre sa moustache
vous avez promis des surprises donc là
effectivement mais je n'arrive pas à
avoir de conclusions avec les anecdotes
que vous me racontez donc vous quelle
est la bonne à conclusion c'est que le
but me semble-t-il le souci principal de
la ministre mme semblent être les
festivals qui sont un moment très
important et qui pourrait être qui
pourrait marquer une espèce de reprise
d'une vie proche de celle qu'on
connaissait autrefois d'où les
expérimentations mentale puisque le
problème c'est le problème des
spectacles de boue les musées en effet
dans la mesure où le nombre d'entrées
est facile à contrôler dans la mesure où
on ne touche rien enfin on est censé n'a
rien touché en tout cas et oui sinon ça
va faire encore que non pour tout vous
dire j'avais hâte de lycée qui était
aveugle et lui il avait le droit de
toucher les statuts
c'était une privilèges dans certains cas
les rôdeurs par exemple et donc quoi
qu'il en soit je pense que les musées en
effet ça devrait pouvoir oui mais je
pense ce que la ministre a annoncé elle
réfléchit d'abord au musée il ya un truc
quand même les théâtres ça marche pas
pourquoi ça marche pas parce que ça
n'existe pas il n'y a pas des théâtres
il ya des tas de sorte de théâtre qui
n'ont rien à voir si vous prenez la
comédie française c'est une chose mais
non c'est pas ça que je veux dire si
vous pouvez pas contrôler c'est à dire
la comédie française fait une place aux
autres ils l'ont fait quand il a joué
plus à la comédie française y jouer
mariner mais ils l'ont ils l'ont fait
bon mais si vous prenez par exemple
l'inde était à dans lequel se produisent
les chanteurs débutants le sentier des
halles qui est qui et qui est dans une
cave qui n'est pas agréé ou en tout cas
qui est pas erré comme elle devrait
l'être par rapport à un virus elle est
aéré par rapport à une stagnation de
public mais papa par rapport à un virus
tout ça ça s'appelle des théâtres sont
des salles de théâtre elle relève du
même régime juridique
sauf que vous pouvez pas les mettre tous
dans le même sac pour le jeu par contre
les cinémas là je tiendrai pas ça je
comprends pas ça je dois dire qu'il ya
un souci alors je vois bien fhd les
échos mais les savoirs pas non plus mais
je vois bien que les yeux vairons est
arc-boutée sur cette idée qu'il faut pas
ouvrir le cinéma parce que qui dit
ouvrir les cinémas dit il ya un après
cinéma qui fait que etc etc
et c'est trop d'idées peut-être fontaine
je comprends rien de vers en de castex
tout ça c'est que dès qu'on a un petit
quelque chose on crée on crée le
sentiment que tout va mieux il ne faut
pas créer le sentiment que tout va mais
de cette volonté toujours nous dire
qu'il faut faire attention coup là que
ça va aller mal et c'est bon peut-être
que si ça va mieux alors là encore c'est
vrai que ce qui risque d'être démenti
dans les quinze jours à leur jeu mais
moi je serai c'est difficile à dire
c'est vrai que les théâtres paraît très
compliqué mais l'idée d'accompagner les
choses quand ça va mieux quitte à
refaire mais quand ça va moins bien
cette respiration dans ce cas on peut
pas ouvrir et fermer pour un théâtre
s'épouvante alors voici nemazee a
compris qu'ils ne sont pas ses grands
mais c'est compliqué c'est à bien des
égards il ya autre chose sur quoi je
mon attention a été attirée est sans
doute la vôtre ne sera aussi je veux pas
avoir l'air d'être le l'avocat du 9 3
mais il ya un papier de bernard faivre
d'arcier l'ancien directeur du festival
de nyon ce directeur des théâtres et
ancien directeur du festival d'avignon
pendant demandera café dans télérama un
papier dans qu'elle ait dit fais
attention
n'ouvrez pas c'est face au raisonnement
se tient de la manière suivante les
pratiques culturelles n'ont pas changé
depuis qu'on parle de démocratiser la
culture la culture est toujours quelque
chose à quoi on taxait seulement les
gens les plus favorisés dans une société
si vous donnez le sentiment que vous
mettez la culture avant le football vous
fait à l'égard de ceux qui vont au
football vous leur manifesté un mépris
de classe je lui dis ça mieux que moi
qui peut être extrêmement préjudiciable
et encore une fois dans une situation
sociale qui n'est pas loin de la
poudrière
donc voilà je comprends bien que nous
sommes plus pardon mais si je peux
aborder dans votre sens
il ya aussi le fait qu'il faut bien voir
c'est que bien des professions sont
autant attentif et même davantage que
les professions du spectacle qui
bénéficie justement de ce régime des
intermittents
alors qui est très coûteux mais très
très très protecteur après il ya plein
de profession vous alors vous parliez
tout à l'heure d'un restaurateur qui lui
dit avec ce que je touche je monte mon
bras droit très bien mais prenez une
grande brasserie les chefs de rang de la
grande braderie qui gagnait deux mille
euros mais qui se faisait de 1500 euros
de pourboire plus ceci plus cela
puisqu'ils déjeuner sur place et ils se
retrouvent avec leur niveau de vie / 3 y
compris avec les aides vous prenez
toutes ces professions autour des
événements les chauffe les gens qui
amenait les chauffeurs qui a mené les
gens vont en voiture les gens qui jugent
les gardes à l'entrée les tutsis et
énormément de profession justin qui sont
ruinés des gens qui se retrouvent sans
un rond qui n'ont pas leur hymne
intermittents qui n'ont pas les aide
parce qu'ils sont pas ils sont saouls ou
même sous traitants des boîtes donc ils
sont pas ils n'ont pas droit aux
aux aides publiques et qu'ils se
trouvent sans avons donc il ya
énormément enfin il ya des naufragés du
coc vide qu'on ne voit pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas accès au micro mais cela il
faut aussi penser à eux parce que c'est
médias il ya des gens pour qui c'est
absolument dramatique
ils passent entre les mailles du filet
qui est de dz
c'est vrai pour l'événementiel c'est
vrai pour beaucoup de choses tourisme
seules les stations de ski
enfin il y en a on peut énormément de
deux joueurs qui n'ont plus rien et tout
les écosystèmes puisque on accepte les
foules dans les métros on doit pouvoir
ré ouvrir des cinémas les musées en
respectant tous les gestes barrière
estimé etienne alors pas tenu d'y
apposer le passeport vaccinale et
vaccinant le personnel au contact de
vacciner c'est l'unique solution autres
populations touchées les étudiants et
autres personnes fragiles sont en train
de mourir rendez nous nos vies nous dit
florentine
la contagion est hors contrôle il faut
éviter les lieux de contamination au
maximum nous dit philippe c'est très
intéressant doit à chaque fois dans les
dents les commentaires comment s'est
polarisée voir que d'un côté on a pas
mal de commentaires qui demande toujours
un petit peu plus de libéralisation et
d'autre commentaire qui éprouve encore
7,7 craintes et qui eux vont dans le
sens de votre de votre dernier contact
rue vivienne qui disent qu'on confie une
fois pour un look malgré tout on
constate avec le temps sur un an parce
que c'est comme vertigineux de se dire
que fait sa date tout ça ne date que
d'un an qui a un incroyable il ya un an
vous et les premiers papiers pour dire
la france s'inquiète d'une épidémie
c'est un truc de fou on a l'impression
que ça fait dix ans qu'on vit dans ce
machin là le fait donc depuis un an on
constate quand même que la proportion
des gens ou pour dire les choses vite
qu'ils en ont marre et qui trouvent que
l'on ferme trop est en train d'augmenter
alors que celle des gens qui continuent
d'exister qui est forte mais qui était
ultra majoritaire du genre de 80 % des
bus est passé de 90 à 80 puis à 79 60 et
maintenant c'est 50-50 et parfois dans
certains sondages 60 % des gens quand on
demande aux français ce que ma quand il
raison de ne pas re confiné c'est je
crois 65% des français qui disent qu'il
a eu raison par confiner mais on aurait
fait ça il ya six mois c'était l'inversé
même au delà dans le sens du confinement
donc
l'esprit public évolue parce que c'est
aussi de plus en plus pénible pour se
rendre de gens et c'est le nouvel esprit
public
oui mais bel esprit sans espace poids
est fermée qui est un espace culturel
que vous pouvez consulter had sens sans
modération aussi juste à les voires
supplément culturel celui c'est le
douzième je crois qu'on publie cette
semaine donc la troisième semaine c'est
un entretien avec nathanaël karmitz sur
l'avenir des salles de cinéma parce
qu'ils avaient commencé à réfléchir bien
avant la pandémie n'a fait que
potentialiser exagéré de manière
terrible la consommation de vidéos et la
consommation le l'usager vectra dic mais
c'est très intéressant de réfléchir à
tout ça c'est très intéressant de
réfléchir en général et de pratiquer
lusage digital de la vidéo on ne pourra
que vous encourager à ça sur fear alive
d'après des scientifiques on va vivre
encore longtemps avec ce virus ou ces
variants donc apprenons maintenant à
vivre avec et ouvrons tout et tout de
suite nous dit cet internaute c'était la
question quand vous posez sur internet
pensez vous qu'il faut rouvrir dès
maintenant les cinémas et les musées et
vous répondez oui à 72% soit un petit
peu baissé parce que juste au début de
l'émission c'était à 73%
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et on
se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit enfin autour de carl meeus a
très vite sur fear alive
[Musique]